all right we got one more thing we want
to talk about with you dave and i'm
sorry to put you through this but we
need it for the context here hillary
clinton sharing what would have been
her 2016 presidential victory acceptance
speech this is what she was going to say
on january 20th 2017 as she was sworn
into office here is that clip i dream of
going up to her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
and that's when she realized that she
will not be the first president of the
united states i mean i i don't like you
know look hillary clinton it's hard to
watch
god she didn't become present
and then that orange man did that we had
four years and it was all pretty good
thank god that woman
thank god thank god that woman did not
become president
we're gonna have to give you enough
that's all i got for you you never cease
to amaze me beautiful stuff great to see
you and i think i'll see you soon too
sooner than i normally see you right
he added up though um
dave rubin depressingly
come from l.a
great to see you dave thanks so much
see you dad if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell